This yarn might not make the best sweater,
An international team of researchers
“Twistron harvesters.”
These tiny twists consist of a carbon nanotube string,
tied into a tangled weave of carbon,
then submerged in a gel full of ions
When pulled,
carbon nanotubes squeeze together,
decreasing the electrochemical capacitance,
and thereby generating a small current.
Enough to momentarily light up an LED.
Previously, capacitance-change-based
mechanical energy harvesters needed
external voltage to generate electricity
But now, this research shows that carbon nanotubes
can produce electricity just as well,
without the extra juice.
The researchers tested the carbon nanotube
yarn’s
power-generating ability in several situations.
This shirt has a pair of these Twistron yarns sewn in.
When the wearer breathes in and out,
a small amount of electricity is generated,
which could be useful data for medical devices.
Researchers also looked into whether this
tech
could harness power from ocean waves.
The harvesters worked
when placed in ocean-like saltwater,
and were able to generate electricity
when the wave motion tugged on the yarn.
More power can be generated if the harvesters
are hooked up together, with peak power generation
reaching 250 Watts per kilogram.
While these proof of concepts don’t generate
enough power to light your home or
charge your electric car,
the researchers say that due to their scalable nature,
these carbon nanotube yarns may have applications
anywhere reliable kinetic energy is available.